good morning believe nation today's
message is prove them wrong over to you
guillermo del toro you know when they
say oh I would like you to to do this
for me or and I produce a lot of
first-time filmmakers but I don't
produce all the first-time filmmakers
that approach me and I say look if I say
no and you give up I'm sorry to tell you
but it's the wrong job for you because
you live with rejection for decades
sometimes as a director and you end up
making the movie you want to make so if
I say no that doesn't mean I'm right or
I'm wrong you just say him I'll show him
later you know I'm gonna make it and
that fat bastard is gonna have to say I
was so wrong and hit himself in the head
because he didn't do it and I think that
that's the thing to do is like show us
don't tell us you know do the things and
if you do them wrong but you do em in
your own terms that's how I define
success failing in your own terms
so this is an interesting one for me and
I'm conflicted I'm conflicted because
early in my career I was very motivated
by the little man by the haters by the
naysayers by the non-believers but the
people who told me that I couldn't do
something I that was fuel for me to go
out and prove them wrong and show it in
their face and say look what I went out
and did whether it was making my believe
by video that the little man told me
that would never do well and now is over
or almost 2 million views people who
didn't believe in my brand people who
told me I was the worst speaker at the
agency and that motivated me to want to
get better and so that helped me in the
early days of my career when I honestly
think that it comes from a place of
insecurity and I would love to encourage
you guys to get to the point where
you're not motivated by what other
people think of you good or bad
where the self-motivation the
self-confidence is so strong then it
doesn't matter what somebody else says
about you then you want to go out and do
that because you want to go out and do
that not because somebody makes you want
to do that right like your motivation
needs to come from here and not from out
there and I'm saying this knowingly
understanding that earlier in my career
I was very motivated by the little men
and the haters and that actually helped
me get some success and so maybe it's
just a mindset in space that I'm in now
having had some success but I would love
to see you guys not care about the
people who don't like what you're doing
the people who don't like your work the
people who tell you you're not talented
the people who feel like you're never
gonna be a success the people who look
at your product or service and say
that's the worst thing I've ever seen
you're never gonna make it if your
motivation is only to prove them wrong
then it's not coming from a great place
or add much rather you be more powerful
and let that negativity just pound off
you the more you get success the more
negativity you're gonna have by the way
and the thicker the skin you need to
build and the less you want to focus on
what negative people are saying we're
understanding there's a lot of people
there are a lot of people out there even
if you haven't seen one yet there's a
lot of people out there who badly need
what you can give them where if you were
to unleash your inner talents your
abilities your confidence and create and
gift that to the world there's a lot of
people who will love it and focus on
them focus on the positivity and focus
on doing the thing that you want to do
as opposed to doing something to prove
in somebody else wrong so that's my take
the question that they today is are you
doing your business to prove somebody
else wrong or because you deeply want to
make it happen yourself I'm curious do
you agree with younger Evan or current
Evan leaving the cows below I'm gonna
join in the discussion so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever
your one word is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso hey believe nation
we're looking at doing a top ten rules
for success on Guillermo so here is a
sneak peek at some of the clips we're
considering including I hope you enjoy
the bonus but I strive to do is to to to
connect deeply with audiences that like
what I do even if the audience at large
does or doesn't it makes no difference
to me I make weird movies no matter what
size the movie is and they're not for
everyone
and and a lot of people may be puzzled
or say why did he do this way but I only
do things that I hope speak to somebody
in the same fetishistic way that I was
spoken to by people that go too high on
their own supply cuz I get high on my
own supply I make the movies because I
want them you know and I and whether is
robots and monsters duking it out or
it's a post-war fable or whatever it is
they're dumb because I wanna I want to
see them my father bought a few
libraries because he won the lottery
in Mexico and he heard or thought that
he needed a study so he built a library
in the house and he had a big desk he
never ever sat on that desk and he
bought books that sort of buy the food
so he bought an encyclopedia and as I go
period of art and encyclopedia of Health
and classic classics from literature and
I read all of them when I was very young
and especially the anatomical sections
of the of the Medical Encyclopedia
proved very useful but but I was I was
really I became sort of a bookish
disease obsessed young kid and and I
discovered things like you know last of
the meheecans hot
dragon of the Damned Frankenstein Jane
Eyre and Jane Eyre and Frankenstein were
two of the books I liked the most
or it was I started I started doing
films when my father again traded he was
a he was a car he had car agencies car
sales salesmen ships and and he traded a
car for some super 8 equipment than
money and he brought in a super 8 camera
support projector and first of all I
bought some super 8 films in San Antonio
Texas and one of them was Quentin the
Crimson altered with with Boris Karloff
and I I bought a few strange ones and I
was I burned them in the projector from
matching them in reverse and forward
again and again and then I I would just
I love reversed like the basics of film
are always magical reverse slow-motion
things like that like if they're always
beautiful when you see a balloon pop and
then it come it's always beautiful and
there's a great shot into the red shoes
the the the the were the feet come in
and undershoot the laces Ty Cobb that is
magical and it's just reverse
photography so whenever I was watching
it in Reverse I was oh my god I saw
I watched him backwards and forwards but
then I bought in the pharmacy back then
in the drugstore I bought a super 8
cartridge and I put it on the camera and
I shot a little movie with my my dolls
my Planet of the Apes action figures and
and I and I protected it and what is the
most beautiful and that no one has ever
not no time have I ever have the sense
of elation that I have then because I
said I did that and it's on the screen
and it was fantastic